Telefon
Hallo, ich bin Lady Gaga, es ist mir eine Ehre
, mit dir zu sprechen, okay,
nur drei Minuten, bevor ich
auf der Bühne sein muss, lass uns schnell über dein Album sprechen,
es heißt so geboren, ja,
alle sind sehr aufgeregt, die exklusive
Rezension sagte, es sei erstaunlich, eigentlich ist
es das
nicht  schade hoffen wir mal so
der druck auf dir mit der Veröffentlichung
des neuen albums ist sehr hoch auch
weiß keiner mehr was von dir zu erwarten ist
du bist ein sehr unberechenbarer freak wie du
selbst sagst hat das was
mit dem titel von dir zu tun  album
ich bin nackt wie ein baby ich bin so geboren
okay
es ist
jetzt kompliziert gaga nummer eins frage ist ist da
irgendwas unerwartetes in deiner hose
nein erzähl ihnen nicht ich habe einen penis
der langweilig ist
sag ihnen ich habe einen
eine sprechende Vagina, was ja, eine sprechende
Vagina, die in chinesischem Dialekt spricht
, das ist gut für den asiatischen Markt. Wir haben es geschafft.
Ich muss mich beeilen, du bist die Beste